hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba oh
do I love it please please I'm an
independent woman I have uncomfortable
I've been on YouTube before I know the
comments are already coming I'll just
rip the band-aid off I know I look like
a boy cool nah man you know YouTube is
spoken in the past I'm sure they haven't
changed their minds in the meantime
you're a great-looking boy oh thank you
I mean I'm a hot little boy but I am all
these are wildly inappropriate so
there's this trail that came out a while
ago and I saw the thumbnail for it I
just wanted to do this one okay it's
called the perfect date you've seen up
to all the boys I love right to all the
boys I've loved before yes
whoa yeah I've seen yeah you seen it
sincerely one of those movies that
challenges you as an adult to not be
attracted to the teenager Michael
Jackson would love this video I forget
how to say this guy's last name he's
that that gorgeous looking man no no a
centaur or something Noah and Timothy
sha'lame there's been a challenging few
years for for adult actors who play hot
teams most importantly adults watching
it
knowing that technically the actor
playing this teen is an adult but you're
still like am i attracted to a teen in
spirit no no yes I get away with it I
follow him on Instagram as everyone
should do you my girlfriend could cheat
on me with him and I'd be like tell me
all the bad yeah yeah I think I think
all of our hall passes are Noah No
my Hall Pass is Noah for me acting
already not great I get to set up the
premise of the movie she's gonna find
out that he was paid no yes that let it
let it all fall that was just probably
super hot right yeah she's like I'm not
like other girls I'm so jaded
look at her with her leather jacket she
doesn't give a spot oh wait this is
getting crazier the plot thickens drop
oh oh dude come on can't you see she's
right
I agree but riverdale here yeah that's
her she's probably looking hot as ever
okay it's
Oh
so many less than okay
yeah so whatever I love it um a couple
thoughts definitely are just a couple
really not gonna be as good as to all
the boys I've loved before we don't know
that no I know it we don't know that no
but I know it though and I'm sorry I'm
gonna watch it it's gonna be a delay
every single character is annoying
though that's the problem
I'm not rooting for any of them why
they're all perfectly shallow yeah well
they're all really hot in their skin is
perfect so I'm rooting for them just
because well not the main love interest
girl not Riverdale chick main love
interest girl is like still very
attractive but you know not super
attractive in terms of Hollywood movies
you know what I mean I refuse to
participate in this demeaning
objectifying conversation no yeah I know
your thing
you know she's not she's not a more
interesting look as some people have
said I think she's still attractive
that's just like yeah you know like they
didn't go with it could have been more
realistic if they wanted to yeah I don't
know that means that just makes me sound
like a dick she's annoying because she's
like oh I'm over all of it it's all
stupid the way she's tired of the world
we're all tired of that character trope
he's becoming a gigolo in this movie
right yeah what he's doing teenager a
full-on prostitution it's just like
sleeping with them yeah if that was part
of the attention he'd just be better
than that it's like you pretty much a
gigolo yeah it's like a male escort
but he doesn't have to sleep with them
he can if he wants yeah if he builds a
trusting relationship the whole thing
with the cousin me the the main girl
being asked to go and I'm like this girl
couldn't get a date to home I just feel
like she could have I think maybe what
it is is that she's anti yeah that she's
anti and that her parents are like but
please go and she's like well if you
find me a date like I'm sure that's
probably more than okay have you set up
everything I'll go it also that seems
like he's doing a very similar character
to who he did it to all the boys in love
before in terms of the main love
interest is with this one girl but then
there's this thing was like now my real
goal is to get
other chick but buddy and I'm gonna
realize I'm really in love with the same
exact guy it's like the same exact
character yeah everything I've seen him
in has been kind of like I know I'm
super hot but like I'm actually also a
good guy and I have struggles twists
yeah some hot people are also nice
you're not like revolutionising yeah I
know you're still my Hall Pass I will
say Timothy sha'lame is a little bit
higher on my list but if he's
unavailable it's Noah for me as well I
like a malnourished the way that I might
look like a little boy he kind of looks
like a lesbian we balance each other I
can't sorry I know we're not here to
talk about shall of May but I will I'm
gonna say one more time if you're out
there hit me up
we are the exact same age it could work
this is a weird promo oh dude this
reminds me of what was that Freddie
Prinze jr. 90s movie one word he's like
he like
ugly girl Alba she's really hot which is
Meyer I refuse to take off my glasses I
can't have anybody know that I'm
secretly hot every teen movie has to
have some like kind of over-the-top
premise sure to like make the main
character kind of choose between two
people the person that Bailey that
Bailey is expected but that the audience
most expected is the one they end up
with and you know if he ends up with
Riverdale then they have transformed the
form then I doubt it
the one benefit of the I mean yeah she
looks like just typical why would you be
with this [ __ ] personnel she's a
terrible dancer that is the like I'm
telling you how to feel about her well
like you don't want him to end up with
her yeah that's something mean don't get
me wrong everything you're saying I'm
like well what the trailers
communicating I'm like yeah yeah I'm
like a thousand percent on board with
everything the one thing is when I saw
the trailer to all the boys I've loved
before I thought a similar thing I'm
like well this looks cliche and
predictable and technically on paper
like its plot points it plays out like a
typical romantic comedy sure with a few
exceptions for all we know maybe when we
watch the actual execution we're like
it's actually a lot better than that too
in a trailer yes no I'm I'm an Aussie I
like cliche romantic on me - I was gonna
say me saying that I can predict
everything that's gonna happen as we all
can it's not an insult to this movie I
would say my only real insults to this
movie are that I think I'm gonna have a
hard time actually liking any of these
characters and this remains to be true
in both movies Noah you're so beautiful
you're a bad actor I'm sorry I like him
oh I did you I'm what I'm trying to say
is I've few criticisms I'm on board for
this movie those are the main two the
first two seconds of this trailer are
him way over acting he hasn't had a
chance to maybe demonstrate as much
nuances like a Timothy shallow me yeah
well because you know what Hollywood's
been just treating him like a piece of
meat because that's what he yeah let's
give him the opportunity to be a piece
of meat with a little more nuance
a little more to show donate it I don't
need him to grow as an actor he makes
I'm gonna show up front in line for
every single movie he makes until he's
inevitably cancelled or saying something
probably at the front of the line of my
Netflix streaming service every day you
know sometimes you just gotta use a
phrase what you actually mean is
refreshing Netflix you know what I'm
sorry there is no actual line I thought
you said you're gonna show up at the
front of the line for every movie is in
that's what I was bouncing off of no no
I know and what I meant by that is you
know our improv is going terrible yeah
no absolutely no chemistry this is going
bad
I tried yes I much like I'm sure the
actors in this film because they were
cast on I think looks an age alone
headshot yeah it looks like they could
play younger and they're legal to be on
set for as many hours as we need them
yes let's use them and legal for all the
adults watching this movie to fantasize
about okay all right guys thanks for
tuning in for the perfect date let's all
be pleasantly surprised by both the
acting and the character development not
surprised at all by how I'm sure
thoroughly enjoyable this movie is
regardless of those two it'll be both
yeah guys you can subscribe to the
recheck nature notification belt follow
Anya on social media
yeah catch you guys later thanks so much
bye-bye
Hey
I'm edgy I'm an edgy comic hey-ya
pushing the boundaries you know a comics
edgy when they self declare they're edgy
comic yeah I mean honestly that is kind
of true a lot of energy comics that is
all that can talk about how edgy I am
listen we're gonna talk about culture is
trying to silence me go ahead I just
tried to silence you oh we need to find
a middle ground here